each year Microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the World including leading
scientists renowned experts in
Technology Book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so anyway um these sles Are
Not very important
um quite frankly I think more Records Uh
and kind of pointers for All Of You are
interested in what I'm going to Touch
Upon but I would really like to reflect
a little bit with what I heard Yesterday
I think there were a number of very
interesting presentation especially from
the Columbia authorities  from the
President from the director ofen And I
like to share with All Of You I think we
are in a small audience which is very
good So You know um Don't hesitate to
interrupt and like to have more dialogue
than you know boring PT Uh  indigestion
or ingestion whatsoever so what I really
Going To Do First Start with a few
comments so they're not in the slides I
Wanted to add them but I didn't have any
internet connectivity here which is
little bit peculiar given the stat of
the  Art of the venue Uh But You
know Maybe you know Maybe you want to
Keep captive audience I try to make my
audience captive Because I say
interesting Thing Rather than stopping
the internet but that is just a
philosophical degression so um It's not
My First time  in Colombia It's not My
First time in Cartagena It's a beautiful
Place i' like to spend the Rest of my
life here with Marcia marquez um yeah Is
A Good Place as a Nice um and I'm not
saying that Just You know just to waste
your Time Just Because I came here well
actually My First projects that involved
Uh Colombia scientists very much in
collaboration With Your research Network
with Renata
um you know with I was very pleased you
know to see The People from Renata here
Again there was many years ago  but not
that many years ago that was around 2004
at that Time I was very I was not in
Microsoft research at that Time was I
was essentially developing large
distributed computer infrastructure
using Great Technology Great Technology
at that time What the distributed
computer infrastructure at the moment
and as part of Major European investment
we decide also to Connect better with
the emerging and Uh you know the very
dynamic vibrant Uh computer
computational Science Community in Latin
America and we decide to have a
specific action as part of the Clara
Network networks and Renata  was Was and
Still is Uh very dynamic National res n
in Colombia so at that Time we Start and
we eventually started a project Where
thinking some of you might be aware call
el and then Had various various
incarnation and follow up And I think el
in some  form is Still up and running Now
so I'm Very Happy to have seen that
early development of m you know be
continue anyway I'm telling this to Say
that Time there was Of course a
Major event Which I think It was not
inan  I was in bogot losers And I didn't
come Because my family was too scared
Say You know you don't go to Colombia
Every Time we open the tv There is
people you know taken away In The Jungle
and you know well we don't  t want you Uh
we Still need you at home so I didn't
come then I came When we Start to
discuss the establishment of the
biodiversity center here in Colombia Uh
there was much later at that Time I was
already in Microsoft that was probably
2007  Something Like That I came Uh it
took a Long Way there were no That I Fly
you know to Bogota from the Cities in
central Europe Where I Live so It was
took me a long Time and Had Five
bodyguards well okay I was with with
Orlando  so W the bodyguards W Not For Me
for him but anyway Five bodyguards Now
this
Time Just call American Express Book my
trip that Fly from Frankfurt to bogota
perfect I bogota I felt safe came here
extremely safe and you see a New
government The spent Good  fraction of
their speech Not Just telling the usual
formalities but really give you the
sense That There is enthusiasm and a
plan to really invest in education Uh
research and Technology and then the
following Talk by the Uh director or
President of from conim he really went
deeper  into that sh that Of course There
is Still a Long Way to go Because when
you See That only What is
0.3 of the gross National produ is
invested in in research That's Bad It's
even worse than the the nation well the
country we originally came from Italy
which is 1% Which for European standards
Pretty low if you compare you there were
some good comparison with Israel japan
the nordic countries in europe Where you
know they all above 2 3% so I think
There is Still Long Way to go but at
least we  see
political Will to Push education
research and Technology Which has the
fundamental to promote Technology
transfer to promote innovation and then
is the beginning of a kind of virtual
Circle you invest in education you
produce good Science Science produces
good Technology and the Technology
produces good business and  the business
reject through a proper section hoping
that in Colombia people Pay tax not like
in my home country nobody ta So You know
the virtual Circle cannot possibly work
So You know by the business the one that
is generated you reject and then the
idea of ​​taxing  taking a percentage an
important One 10% of the royalties that
is not a New idea Michelle B did that in
chile Uh When She was elected Now She's
no longer in that position so that was
probably four five years ago and She
decided to tax royalties on  their
Rich copper Industry 1% here is 10% Over
10 years If I understand correctly
President Sant statement so That's big
and That I think is a Step in the right
Direction Of course It's not the end of
the Story When I Saw brake the way In
which you know that investment is going
to be implemented I'm a little bit
worried there are too many boundary
conditions I Think You know also I
the interest of making everyone
Happy and if you really want to be
effective Uh Don't try to  make everyone
Happy that is unfortunately my
frustration with European Union that you
know they try to make everyone Happy
and at the end all investment get
diluted you should really strive and aim
for excellence you do an excellent
proposal and you get approve If the
third proposal coming  from the third
University doesn't matter strive to Uh
excellence And adv I can say Of course
that is going to put the decision people
on Board in a difficult political
situation Colombia Still a relative
small country in term of people in ter
of decision places so  you might be
exposed to a lot of political pressure
which is a big Danger so try to use you
know peer review try to use
International scientific Community you
know try to bring people from the
outside World to come and advise your
funding agency your advise your review
boards that is you know modest advice I
can Give so That I think is what I
Wanted to give is a kind my reflection
having been Yesterday to all Those very
interesting presentation I Think You
know Colombia is really in a very
interesting moment Uh and Everything
goes  Together You have a good economic
growth that is the basis to invest in
research and innovation and then is the
basis for democracy I mean you cannot
have democracy If People are struggling
with with Survival and Vice Versa
without democracy it is very difficult to
have
you know a  vibrant and an effective
scientific environment so that is
basically you know my immediately Hot
and personal Uh reaction so I'm not
speaking on beh of Microsoft research in
Any possible way so that is just my Uh
emotion That I Wanted to share with you
after having  spent quite some Time with
you guys and talking to various people
so Now what I'm Going To Do I'm going to
say Uh very few words on Cloud computer
I Think You know you heard already from
many Any More technical competent video
than me  Uh you know about cl computing
so I don't really go to need to go in
Any Uh detail Just just a couple of
statements few slides um just to make
sure that we Speak about the same Thing
you know I I have a long history of
distrib  computing Myself And I remember
When you know 10 years ago people Start To
talk about gre computing everyone
was doing gre computing you know two
cables and two computers there gre
computing was not true now I see a
little bit the same Thing you everyone
Who has been  doing gre computing as a
cluster as a c cluster W they're doing
Cloud computing unfortunately the
reality is a little bit different so I
will I will Just Uh Start with you know
few slides to make sure that we Speak
about the same Thing so Cloud computing
emerging approaches to computational s to
Support computational Science I will say
more but basically the Uh you know Uh
Tony hay gave a great presentation
explaining know the force paradigm so I
don't need to go into that but It is
essentially the message by making
computing  More affordable more
sustainable and particular dimension
tells you know the amount of computing
and Data process you can make available
even to Non computer experts in
computational Science is such is going
to change is changing the paradigms is
really Uh sustaining the the Vision that
Tony was sharing  with us Yesterday so I
think that is a very important component
and the technological basis That are Going
To talk is really Data Center
virtualization of course you know many
of my former colleagues that you know
this grid infrastructure and they say
well that is Cloud computer You  Change
few things well I I don't agree I mean
large Data Center and virtualization at
all Level are the new Two technological
foundation of Cloud computing so Uh
clearly distrib computer is not New I
mean in the ecclesiastes I Think You
know Uh King solomon says  that There is
Nothing New Under the Sun and Again that
is a phrase has been said many many
Times in super computing you know We all
try to evolve from the same ideas but
Technology comes in and Technology makes
the difference Because it changes the
size and size  matters in computing so Uh
If I reflect the experience at Myself um
working before joining Microsoft and
also continuing after join Microsoft in
leveraging Major European investment in
computing that has been a Major
investment One billion Euro Over The
Last 10 year just to Support the
infrastructure the  1 billion euro
doesn't include the Support to the
Direct computer Science application so
in That context I will say few words
about Venus which is a project Which
brings Uh to computational Science Uh
Cloud computing infrastructure coming
from essentially from Microsoft
essentially based on Asia  but also
bringing in super computing and see How
can super computing Play a role into
that environment and I'm Very Happy to
see
Uh to see Okay What I've done wrong to see
matteo Valero sitting in the Front Row
and smiling to me So  You know we do have
super computing components into this
project We also have a more
conventional cluster Uh Provider like the kth
institute in stockholm and and a few other
things So You know I will I will cover
that and see how Venus really plot
inside the European Uh  landscape and Uh
leveraging Cloud computing so Again the
very First Thing I Wanted to say about
Cloud so that is a kind standard
definition you know model of computation
Data storage that basically scale With
Your needs and you know you Pay As you
go Uh and basically if  you can afford to
give you access to an Almost
Unlimited Remote Data Center
capabilities but that could also be said
for Cloud computing and many other
previous version of distributed
computing Uh the important thing is that
you know the Cloud is is you know
backhand that can  Support many on the
Mobile application so that is a New
Thing Technology Now allow to have you
know very smartphones that even too
Smart Because they Start to intrude With
Your Life Every Second minutes Because
Now you know everyone Can Send you a
presentation or something or Everything
on on your Smartphone and That's going to
really attract your attention and you
know really Kill most of the normal
social human interaction Which I think
is the drawback But You know we cannot
Stop The progress so everyone is
using a Smartphone and you know there
all  let's say intelligent terminal that
are going to change the way In which we
interact in computer you hear more and
more and Discover also in this event New
this natural New user interfaces and all
Those kind of seem for obvious Reason
they have a limited local Power Uh  in
terms of how much you can put of
resources and therefore they need a
pervasive environment backend to Support
Those applications so that Again New not
they New as a compset but New Because
the Technology that We have today was
not available only two three years ago
and the historical roots already
mentioned them Back on you know we learn
How to distribute Our application with
you know Linux cluster everybody has a
Linux cluster in his in his history then
we moved to greek computing When we try to
put the cluster Together and Now We  have
the emergency of a Fantastic Technology
Center that allows you to go One Step further
and One Step further in virtualization
so Again um slide That probably My
Microsoft colleague has seen many Time
but that just to make the point
once more about that only with very  very
large Data Center you can Reach its
economy of scale So You can really make
storage Uh processing and the management
you know at the end of the day is the
human factor to manage a computer Center
well If You're in University and you
just have  a cluster Windows cluster
Linux cluster No matter you can abuse
some of your phd student to become
operator System manager and Brand the
System for you but you know if you are
in the commercial world and if you
know Those Solution Don't scale You
cannot  have you know if you grow you
know 1000 phd student all becoming a
System program So The very good thing is
the administration I mean the number of
computing Element the number of
processor the number of Everything of
all the components That One single
person can administer when  you go to
This scale is incredible so you know
so this kind of economy scale was not
possible with greek computing was not
possible with the previous versal disb
computing and is now made possible and
that is just One of the First generation
I mean you know  of Data Center so
Data Center is a Major component of
Clark Andy motivation are obvious Four
already said many Times clearly by
concentrating Those very large Data
Center you can be much more
environmentally responsible or friendly
Because you can really mak Data Center
you know Being  very efficient the
Speed ​​at Which you can provide your
service if you have very very large Data
Center For Any application for Any kind
of you know virtual computational
Science System you need to deploy you
know you can deploy 100,000 servers in
a few hours Rather than the
months the year that we Take if you
Wanted to do physically so Again There
is a very interesting opportunity in a
country like Colombia Where you want to
go Fast you have time to Catch up you
know going Back to what we heard
Yesterday and Again  if you really want
to build a physical computing
infrastructure it Will take you quite
some long time
So You Still have to do that Because you
probably want for a number of Reason
including National app and real Time
response and Security and privacy you name
it to have  your own physical private
infrastructure But You know by
contracting out to providers of Data
Center of Remote Remote Data Center etc
that you can Get In The business much
faster So You can really Catch up and
you get status of art so when you
Connect to Microsoft  or Any of Our
competitors dat sent you get status of
Art There is a tremendous generation
Data Center I we show slides Now move
very Fast Every Every two years There is
a New generation resilience you know
Black c disaster i mean Again You're
part of  a vir organization Or You have a
Major event in a country While you can
move your resources somewhere Else and
and you know The Last one is really All
About seeing Uh the infrastructure as a
service Every very simple and interface
and is
virtualized so That's what I  Wanted to
say I mean if you Look at the time scale
you see from 2005 2010 Four Generations
of Data Cent so that Was and Again and
Every Time in a new generation one Step
for modernization of the components and
virtualization so Still kind of you know
very  well integrated Data Center but
conventional Data Center Uh so It's
really the server the the F then Every
integrated in racks But You Still need a
conventional building and then you Start
to move Everything container Technology
so One Step Four in using modular
components and you can  get away from
buildings which is a tremendous saving
and then now I mean is is one Step
Forward with the fourth generation and
Again I encourage those of you are
interested to Get In Touch with
Microsoft in Colombia and see if you can
be given n Our  you know technological
Evolution Uh roadmap and Maybe organize
a visit for those of you to some of Our
Data Cent you can really see how Fast
development is that so that is a
tremendous enable and you know I mean
people Now talks about you know private
and public  clouds so that would be you
know call it public clouds Because you
know you share the Cloud with the other
customer of that particular Company But
You can use the same Technology in house
in a country to build your own private
and you can have hybrid So You  can have
you know container install at your
premises and you have a Remote Company
Uh managing the container so that You
keep your Data locally very well
protected You can put fences you can put
you know Military guards around But You
know the cost of managing that is  offset
to Uh a service Provider so I think that
is Fantastic Technology that can really
help people who have Money like you guys
you know have and he has time to c you
know very short time to Catch up with
that Technology you can Catch up very
quickly  Provider you know You Don't
spend years to decide How You're going
to spend the money that you are going to
get with the royalty so try to be agile
and Fast um Ok that is just a
characterization that you know the fact
that is  now Cloud computing doesn't mean
that you know conventional
supercomputers you know uh uh so matteo
can relax Are Not Any longer neededy yeah
super compu Still needed for a
number of applications and particularly
if you have a fine grains parallel MP
application etc but then  really the map
reduced a parallel programming model
that originally Drive Cloud computing
and you know more and more Uh that is
going to be the prevailing Uh platform
for computational Science um Tony
Yesterday already covered that in his
Talk well I haven't seen his talk before
so I put that as Just in Case but I
Think You know he explained very well
You know the Evolution Uh um tos making
Science easier using computing so making
Tools available to make Science easier
not really Getting in the way which has
been unfortunately of the experience
That with gre computing Where before
really became capable to Access the
tremendous computing power gre computing
was capable To deliv You have really to
become an expert in computing And then I
think is something we can get away Now
with with parking
Beauty So what are we doing  in Microsoft
Uh exam computing Group Microsoft
research Microsoft connection to really
help Boost in this process so really
make Cloud computing available for
computational Science and enable a Fast
grow a Fast implementation the Force uh
uh paradigms that Tony was mentioned
Yesterday so in Us Our colleagues have
Last year February 5th 2010 they
announce a joint call for proposal the
National Science foundation and That's
now is up and running so there's been I
Don't Know Something Like 20 application
been selected so basically Microsoft
provide the the computer infrastructure
and the application are developed  by
um you know We founded the National
Science foundation similar in Asia in
europe We have two things we decide to
engage with the epcc the the physical
and Science research council in UK in
France with ina and Germany with hlrs
which is a super computer distrib
computer  Center belonging to the
University of stutgart in Germany and
then in parallel have really at European
Level a specific project following the
rules of the European Union taking the
challenge and the risk to submit a
proposal and compete with everyone Else
And Be successful Uh with the  V project
so that the you know the solicitation
was Last year we were approved Last year
we Kick off the Pro in June And I will
say a few more words later on so
um so V um ok I mean you know you know
that in all project  you need to Have a
Nice name so what better name V Which
probably good match with Latin America
Because you have all Those Network
Renata Clara the all have beautiful name
of ladies so How about V was a good
Thing and then once you have decided the
nickname the acronym you have to reverse
engineer and Come To a justification
for that and most of the time they're
very complicated so in Case I don't even
know so V see come from you There is
virtual There is Cloud computer
Something Like that  anyway the aim is
supporting user Community communities
with the development deployed of user
friendly user friendly is an important
component Services to Support the
Production Uh of Cloud application so
that is a little bit the Mission
statement of the Project
and like All the European Union projects
is  a consortium so It's Not Just
Microsoft Clear Microsoft Play an
important role we provide most of the
infrastructure but as I said There is
also contribution from that Partner and
you see Uh the various um Uh partnership
and you see There is a Distribution
between Partner that provide  user
scenario There is the overall software
architecture development There is the
Provider of the Cloud infrastructure and
then There is the additional important
Element of training The People and
disseminating the result of the project
which is Of course a very important
component and you know most of the
project you find in European Union
suppor project but also at National
Level they all share this kind of
characteristic a consortium you know
working together toward certain goals
and a distributional role as a
responsibility inside a project Uh the
Seven scenario I Think You are
potentially interesting so  we try to
cover relative wide Area you know from
structur analysis building
infrastructure management biodiversity
aquam Maps that is in collaboration with
with the un agency the Food and
agriculture organization so that has
potential good links with What's going
on in in brazil and Colombia latin
America etc  propagation we have been doing
that with
the civ defense agency in gre
potentially interesting for you guys
informatica same Thing computation
System biology in collaboration with Our
joint institute of compal System biology
with University of Trento drug Discovery
and you know Those are the partners
Those Partner providing the  internal use
cases for the project um and then we
decide OK So What's the plan so We have
the infrastructure provided yeah I've seen I
have a watch I Still have five minutes
yeah
um Yes five minutes um so basically We
have the infrastructure providers That  I
mention Microsoft Uh Barcelona super
computer Center kth in stockholm so
Together we try to make an integrated
interoperable infrastructure on Which
then other partners plugins Seven user
scenario and we gave ourselves one
year to make sure that Everything was up
and Run and Now Everything Is  up running
So You know by Magic we manage so couple
of months ago we issue an Open call
Because Now We are ready to the new
scenario not originally foreseen in the
proposal so we managed to identify
400,000 eur is not a gigantic amount of
money but to  Found 15 pil of projects we
send a solicitation for an op call
that concluded a couple of weeks ago and
we got actually More Than 60 valid
application that fulfill All the
requirements and you know the the
application the infrastructure is
again supported by by Barcelona  Uh
stockholm and
Microsoft 60 application received and
the selection has Now been completed so
We have pick up the top 15 and We Will
Kick off this New application in an
event in brussel june actually June 9
and 10 Not Just the 10 so that Give a
Distribution  So You can see there again
many subject cover Go from in economic
and financial he Science civil
engineering chemistry Uh
psychology physiology molecular cell
genetic biology Everything so that is a
confirmation How powerful the Cloud
infrastructure is you can Support a very
broad spectrum of applications you see
from from many I think There is a slce
then let say yeah the Distribution
So You See um application coming from 17
different countries and is m from
academia research Cent but also we Start
to see growing interest in small medum
Sign
enterprises Now as A Part  Of That I
remember beginning in my few reflection
beginning I said that you know many
years ago When I was Still young and
handsome Uh I'm Still young and not some
Any longer But You know you know the
project we fix that you know When We
Will  Do you know genetic Thing um so If
You remember said Ok we Had Project
europe and we try to actually we
successfully expanded to to latin
America not only to latin America we did
the same Thing you know in the North
africa India China so Now We are
to Reproduce the same model and Again a
good example I mentioned that Because
It's Of course interesting Just off the
press is a project that Will Start in a
couple of weeks Time in June Uh eu trying
brazil Open Bio I think is interesting
Because here is brazil  We have seen is
doing quite good in investing in
innovation and research and in education
and they decide that One of the problem
probably share with Colombia most Latin
America you have the problem to increase
your scientific International
collaboration is already not Bad but I
Think You  can do better So The Brazilian
government Last year decided to Uh
launch with the European Union a joint
call and is an interesting very agile
System you know is mandatory to have a
collaboration Between a Group of scien
in Brazil a Group of scientists in Europe
and they  Go and submit a proposal the
brazilian to the brazilian authorities
european to european authorities and you
go in two parallel evaluation if both
succeed you get the money both Side and
the project got approved in one of the
two phases the other fail as well so
really Force  a a Street collaboration so
We took the Venus consortium we built a
small subset mat was kind Enough to
accept to Take the leadership and so
this project is led so Let Me go to the
next
slide yeah this project is led Uh on the
European Uh Side by  the
bsc as Microsoft research we Just Play
an advisory role and Again Will be Happy
to provide resources but We Are Not
formal partners and then in brazil the
the reference center on environmental
information creates Was the leading Partner
so we built this to consortium Together
and actually  It's not true that the red
tape in in funding is that Bad Because
you know we submitted we built
Everything around Christmas Uh so It was
a tough Christmas for many of Us we
submitted A proposal On January the 29th
and February 15 both proposals were
approved and  June 1 we Just Kick off The
Reason we Just Kick off on June 1 and
not on March 1st is simply Because
everyone is very busy So You can go
very Fast If There is the political Will
so my adv you have seen Yesterday strong
statement from your  President profit is
a winds Of opportunity You can go very
Fast but c the Now that is what has been
done with Brazil so Why not doing the
same Thing in Colombia and having you
know the Colombian government to launch
a joint call for proposal with European
Union  I'm at the end of my Time so I'm
Going To accelerate and you know matteo
you speak just a little less
okay um So yeah but Maybe okay that you
know for people interested in the
project I think you should be so that is
require too much time so come and see me
But You know the slides I Send the
slides you know many Times so they must
be everywhere around the infrastructure
here So let's let's jump to conclus so
so the Bio the Bio open the Open Bio
brazilian project european  Union is
essentially Venus infrastructure
extended to brazil and bringing on
additional application very much around
biodiversity so I think It's a very
interesting subject for you guys the
details are in The slides Happy to
discuss video of So let's jump to the
conclusion not to exceed much  my Time
so Uh We didn't have time to go into the
details but I think I remind you of
other presentation Enough to hope
convince you theing is becoming a
powerful enabler for computational
Science but Still you need to have good
scien do computational having a  good
enabler is just a mean to an end is not
the end itself Easy to use is very very
important you don't want all your
computational scientist also to become a
System manager or a computer scientist
and affordable for Remote institute in
less developed country I  mean with cl
computing you don't need to really be
in the best connected country in the
world with the best computer Center etc
you can really get up to Speed ​​very
quickly is an excellent platform for
preserving and sharing Data I mean Again
Tony other  speaker Yesterday they spoke
very much of the importance of
preserving scientific Data especially
When They are built produced with the
public funding with taxpayer Money and
Again the Cloud you know put it on the
Cloud everyone can ass easily and and
cheaply very very important that What
happens  of all Those project funded by
The European bf Who they All the Data
locally On A cluster three years later
There is no fund Any longer the cluster
get you know Uh uh disposed What
happened of the Data so That's That's
very very enabler of course you
Still have to decide you Still have to
implement the System from preserving the
Data there were some example that Tony
made of some Data Were supposedly you know
to be digitized and made available
forever and It was a Major failure in UK
So You Still need to  do the job but
at least you have a very powerful
enabler as m
connection okay I I didn't have any time
to explain What we do foring in micros
conne but essentially it has been covered
by other colleagues essentially we try
to Foster collaboration between Our
scientists and  scientists outside
Microsoft so We are here I mean I'm here
I'm happy to advise and Support
experimental accus Technology I I try to
give you a few Uh a
few ideas and I'm happy to discuss
further I'm Still here until tomorrow  Uh
lunch Time So You know if you if you
know anything I've said was interesting
for you guys I hope It was Just grab me
Uh anywhere in the Conference and I'll
be Happy to discuss with you and with
That I thank you and  sorry for having
exceeded for minutes Thank
you there One quick question Maybe we
can take it otherwise we move to the
next
speaker okay
So it was to good it was completely useless
okay So Uh Catch Me Catch Me outside
Okay thank
you thank you good morning to everyone
is  my third Time in kartagena this Time
for war for 25 minutes and
Microsoft inviting
meime and Will switch to spanish to
presentation
so then I am going to talk a little about
the future
exafs computers and within them about the work
some of the work that we are
doing in  Barcelona research
In that
direction This is the fastest supercomputer
in the world
Today it is in
China It is made up of many
nodes, small machines, each of the
nodes has pentium and has
envy accelerators and those nodes are connected
through an interconnection network of
high speed so that the processors
can exchange information they can
run an ap at the same time
one thing that is important is the number
of cores processors
186000 the maximum speed you get
4.7 petaflop is the peak speed of the
mouth
and when it runs  The test with which
supercomputers are classified
obtains a speed of 2.5, that is, the
efficiency obtained by running that
application is 53 percent and another fact that
interests me is that it consumes 4
mw 4
mw well, this is the table of  The top 10
in the world are classified twice
now there will be a new table in June in
Germany in November in the United
States if we look at the computer
we had first is this the second is a
Crey computer and notice that in this column there is
the speed of  peak, that is, each
processor has a speed,
we multiply it by the number of
processors and it gives us the
maximum speed, the speed at which we are certainly not
going to go and this is the speed that is
really used to classify them
by running a very simple application
than a very simple application.  Parallel, which is
solving a system of equations, the
Lu decomposition is done, then
the two triangular systems are solved.
The number of processors and what happens
is that number one is this, but
I would prefer to have number two because
it is more efficient, there is little software.  For
machines based on nvidia at the
supercomputing level we are making
a lot of progress there and a little bit what
happens now that with nvidia you look good on the
day of the photo and you have problems the
next day with users precisely
because there is not much parallel software in
these
moments there are two machines in Europe there is
one in Japan two in China and the rest is
in the United States and being on
the list a little depends on how much money you have there
is no secret if you have 85
million dollars as they were used
in China well it could be  Number one, there are
many companies like IBM that if you go with
a lot of money they are going to make you number
one they are going to make you happy by giving you a
machine that you probably won't be able to
use very well and that by the time you
realize it, what you start to know
is already there.  at number 500 at 4 years old, no,
but the experience has been good because
one day you appeared in the photo of the
newspapers and that is important depending
on which people I am not saying Who,
right. So this is what I wanted to
say to this table if we look  How have
the speed of the
processors evolved? I'm going quickly, curiously,
about the compadors running this Impact,
a silly test that we should
change to classify them. It's that the
speed has multiplied by 1000
every 10 years, curiously, so now
many people are
trying the questions that I hope is
for  I sometimes wonder about making
exaflops machines where you can see that the number of
processors is going to be enormous, millions and
millions of processors, trying to
explain why the number of
parallel threads that the application will have to have is
much greater to try to
use those
machines efficiently is also important.  know that
eh this speed of the teraflop 10
raised 12 operations that the
fastest computer gave in 98 now we have
eh 4 cm cu silicon chips that exceed
that speed So that we can see a little
how the speed of these
machines evolves and for example the  iPad that
many of us have, some like
me who don't know how to use it. But it's good to
carry them. It turns out that it
would have been the fastest supercomputer
in the world in the year 85 when it was
the Crey
2. It is data on how technology
logically advances. You will have the information.
on the web but logically if we go from
eight processors to 1024 That
means multiplying by
128 the remaining o is the speed at
which we increase each processor not by or
multiplying the speed by 128 the
number of
processors message that I want to give
now is that a  From now on there is no more
increasing the speed of an
individual processor, as you know, the
only way we can make
more powerful machines is to put many
more processors, which complicates everything,
complicates everything
tremendously. This is a transparency
that I prepared that dates back to June.
One year I didn't have time to do it in
November But hey The idea is very
simple this if we have number one
in June This is the speed that
each Core obtained the red one is how many
cores are there per chip the blue one How many
chips are there per node eh the nodes
Normally they tend to be small with
common memory, easy to program and
then, as I said, those nodes
intercommunicate through an
interconnection network. And then, this is the
number of nodes, this portion, uh, then
you have here,
uh, data on the 500 of them.
the 500 fastest processors in the
world in June of last year, notice
that we can have
personal supercomputers based on
envy cards 4 8 10 teraflops an
enormous speed at the level of a special laptop
but laptop and with GPU and for the
future I will give you more information  Well, if
there are machines, I will give you more information,
but what interests me is that right now we
don't know what
these exaflop machines will be like. The prediction
we make in the BSC
processor speed will logically increase the
number of cores per chip and
The number of chips per node will increase a little but
not much more due to the problems that exist and more
or less 100,000 nodes could be a
reasonable number to reach that
speed of 10 to the power of 18 operations
per
second. These are some announcements that there are about
Avanza technology  In the United
States, as you know, the way
they work with these companies
is that they say, Well, if in 3 years, in 2
years, you are able to make me one of
these machines, I will start
paying you, so these are the forecasts that
the Blue Wat has.  It is installing 10
petaflops, remember that the number one
is now four and a
half peak, there are others, this is with
Power 7 technology, there is with
Blue Gin technology, there are machines, for example, the
sequoya that I had shown you in the
previous one is 20 petaflops, it
would be five times.  faster than now
with 100,000 nodes 96 racs in short eh 6 mw
is a reasonable consumption note that
megawati at least in Barcelona
means a million euros that you have to
pay accordingly multiply by 2500 and it is
millions of Colombian pesos one pass
not the other  thing is that eh a
nuclear power plant has 1000 mw
so see that we can immediately
eat a nuclear power plant with these
supercomputers which is a
justification for manufacturing them
really more machines in Japan or in
cree eh not to just talk about
IBM well  The important thing is that we are
working, as I say, on these machines,
on the manufacturing of these machines and on
the programming, and here is some data
from a committee that we met that
I will talk about later at a global level about how
the issue can go more or less.
We say cores per node we see the years
here we say well from 100 to 500 it
depends on how complex each
Core each processor is true in the
same area of ​​silicon it depends on how
powerful a processor is Or another fits
more or less the speed does not work  to
increase a lot due to Power problems
generated by the heat
eh the flocks this I do not believe these
data that we are going to multiply the
number of operations per second in
these machines at this level Although I am
a lover like my ex who is out there
Luis  former doctoral student working
on vector processors noos per
rack you have some data here The
important thing is this amount that is already
very scary that these machines are going
to consume around 50 mw
it is a lot only the
electricity bill is a lot no and curiously enough these
machines are used to study
climate change it is not
good what is important is that well
in a rack in a rack logically in the
year 18 we have to put all the
power of the Chinese machine the
fastest at the moment no the
technology is going to  allow
the enormous number of processors to do these things,
between 4 and 200 million processors.
How is that programmed? And as
the Cuban singer said, Machín, you should not be
crazy. It is not very difficult to use all this
memory and the number of racks, 400. It is
a lot of work.  Our mother has 48, so
we need a larger chapel, 10
times larger, we are in
negotiations, I will tell you where, but
there are many
racks. How are they made? The truth is that it is
very complex to make these systems. And
if for many years we were not able to do so
with a single processor.  to work I
am a computer architect I am an
Iron Man I am not software no Well
then if we were incapable of working on
operating systems compilers
with a
processor how are we going to assemble these
machines even though we collaborate a lot it will be
very difficult because the terms the
concepts are  relate applications algorithms in the
different
layers How
job scheduling is done What
programming model we use runtime
How
interconnecting we need to make
multidisciplinary teams that
really collaborate to try to solve
minimize the negative effect of these
problems that we are going to see in the design
of these machines and  that are already current that is why
this group exists, for example,
we are about 70 people led by
Jaon Garra and Peter Bean. I am one of
the eight people who is in the
Steering committee and we meet every
three or four months to discuss a little
the problems of  software Hardware all
these things do not concern us so much
eh And within that scheme is the
center that I direct is the
National Supercomputing Center of
Barcelona is the National lapes all
countries especially in Latin America and
we are Latin Well there are these
disputes let's see  who has it
bigger than we say in Spain not the
machine so then well these
disputes have always been decided a long time ago
we started working in Barcelona
I created a group in the year 84 with
parallel computers we bought
64 transputers at that time so
we started working  work and well
create a very powerful group And then
Madrid decided, a strange thing, that the
Spanish supercomputing center was going to go
to Barcelona But we are doing well we have to
provide service we do
research we started with 40 people
to be 70 we are 340 that excess of
staff that  I say that it is not due to
the resources that we have attracted from
companies and the European Union, for every
Euro we receive for research we have
obtained four During the years that we
are working, which are five or 6
years and we have four departments, the
department of sciences
computers Hardware and Software How to
build How to program
applications department working
engineering topics Life Science department 70
people developing software there was
already a lot of talk about database
protein folding drugs Ah well this is
climate change and this is the
applications and then the
service well, here it is the same and one
thing that I am very happy about is that we
have people from many countries. For
example, I personally have three
doctoral students who are paisas, they are
brave people because we work in
computer architecture to optimize
algorithms for the avio for
mp4  and not things like this and we are we have
attracted about 100 people who are from
outside Spain this gives
additional value one thing we have that I am
very proud of is a collaboration that
we started with Microsoft and I encourage you
to continue in that line of collaborating
With multinationals, the important thing
is not the money they give you, which is
important. The important thing is that, as
the vice president of research said,
they are very good at actually
investigating, then the opportunity
you have to collaborate and discuss
with these people, if we had money
we would pay, but on top of that  They
pay us so well we made a center
our mentor is Fabricio Thank
you Thank you thank you very much
Fabricio Thank you and Tony were
pioneers in this so well we have
made this
center we started to work on
transnational Memory having achieved in
that topic perhaps Well the center that
has best  worked there Now it seems that the
issue of transal Memory
but curiously the Blue I know that uses
transational Memory as a supercomputer
and now We are working on other
topics such as operating systems our
programming models applications
for everything that is a
research platform in multicor no  We have
and and another issue that is not there is that
we work on Low Power
vector computers for
telephones well, one important thing to
say here is that in these
European projects we applied to
establish a Latin American
supercomputing network the project has been
granted and for example here in Colombia
Well, I told my friend, the rector
Gabriel Manizales, that he is already very
happy because they are the partners here
and there are other
partners. Luis is the professor who is
collaborating with us. Thank you Luis
because he has always been very positive and
you know when when you don't know the
people and by email Well, no, but well, we
went there, so we are going to
start the project. We have a little
money, 400,000, but enough for what
we asked for. What is it to make a
white paper on the situation in these
Latin American countries? But we can put
others about  supercomputing
second topic we are going to do
workshops where we are going to give
parallel programming languages ​​applications eh
we are going to be very active there and the
objective that is why we ask for it is that
if we are good at doing this I am
convinced that the European Union will dedicate
money to enhance the
supercomputing issues in Latin America This
is the objective where we are
all going Fabricio was talking about Brazil three
years ago it was with Mexico it could be at the
individual level of countries on
specific topics I see that this is good it
can be at a global level by topics if
we say genome issues  Well,
surely in Mexico you will be very
interested in the tomato and El porco, what is the
name of the corn? You too
here in Colombia,
energy, oil, environment, let's
see there, then, although I have little
time, well, our work in it is on
parallel computers. The great advantage
is that  Since 1985 we have
tried in my group to work
collaboratively between
applications, Eros hardware models and
things like that, so no, this
project is already developed,
very large, scalable applications, we
make them for many processors, for
example, the rever St migration is  One
thing that we have developed, I will tell you a
little bit about the software that
Repsol uses and increased the
probability of finding oil in the
Gulf of Mexico by 25%, which is very difficult
because there are these layers of salt that
greatly distort the signal to
analyze it.  very happy because
each puncture is 100 million
dollars and the probability of success is
one in six any increase in the
probability of success is very large the u
terpe is a fusion code for the
elit fusion machine that is being
assembled is  a world-wide
fusion reactor that is starting to explode
in every rage in France, which is
15 billion euros 15 billion
euros even if a little is spent on a
supercomputer and vice versa without
supercomputing that reactor cannot be
done because it cannot be  We really know how
the plasma is going to behave. Eh, then
one
good thing is undoubtedly that the people who
develop this know or are in
contact within the center with people who
know about each other. One issue that I am very
proud of is our programming models.
There are more than 800 programming languages ​​in each university, there is
at least one for each department and there are
professors who have invented more than one
programming model but there is no
experience in using it. A person has
used different programming models
for an application according to or  has
for different applications because
these applications are very large, so
how do they
compare? It's
impossible. We are in the
advisory Bo of all these panels,
but we have developed the Star SS, which
we believe is a very
valid approach to programming any
parallel machine.  from the Cloud to any
multicore without touching the code this is
important I will talk a
little bit we
have done techniques at the software level
at the algorithm level at the
hardware level when the program is executed
load balancing an important topic we
have before we talked about the vampire
we have tools  as good
as the vampire, I agree that they
allow us to analyze the behavior of the
hardware when programs are executed in
mpi. But we also use them to
design the architectures of the future.
The interconnection network is
important. The memory hierarchy is important. It is
important that it has Catch.  or have
local memory Well you can predict
things the interconnection network the networks
used in supercomputers
are killing flies with cannon fire there are no
articles that are really worth the
importance of the network when running
large applications there is no need to go to the
literature We have  tried with
some articles And we have pu our
results we are working on many
topics logically when one has
information about all this is when one
can put What type of processors
would be the best the most suitable
for a certain type of applications
true We have collaborated with IBM
in the  cell design surely the
new cell will not come out but it would have been
very nice because no the best
Hardware and the best software is the one that
has invaded the world not but the one that
sells the most and sometimes the best is not the same
and a good machine  but it depends
on whether the PlayStation 4 is made with
this processor, it is made with an Intel, no. We
have worked very
hard there, for example in
important oil, geologists, mathematicians,
programming language and architects.
This is the software that we developed
for Repsol that has received  many
awards, for example the second prize of
l triple 3 years ago in technologies, the
first was the design of an
IBM memory, programming models, truth, we
have always tried to generate the
greatest expression of parallelism of the
application we are making and without a
doubt that  It is a gra dataflow. How
we obtain this, there are different
programming models, different approaches,
but once we have a
representation of the application in a
dependency graph, in the
runtime when we are executing
we can optimize the execution of
that application and changing the rant Time.
We are going to be insensitive or we are going to
optimize if we are optimistic the use of the
Hardware when they change the Hardware
we have worked there important is that the
programming model has to have
a big vision of the algorithm because
if not yes I think that is a
little bit of doing prefing of making
jump predictors for a processor we have
fought for 20 years and we
have not been Good if now we have a
multicore it is impossible to manage the
memory it is impossible to do perfin it is
impossible to do reuse if we do not have
high level information about the
application our
programming language allows it and this is
an added value How to do it I don't have
time we start from a
sequential program we write down so that we write down the
program dependencies between processes
when it begins to execute a
graph of dependencies is made you see here you have a
little piece  Once you have the
dependencies, the order in which
that graph is executed, while it is valid,
can be any. And that is what
gives us flexibility to optimize the
execution. Then, for example, you can
do eh 1 1
a but two can be this  true And
these could be eh And that's what I'm saying
the beautiful thing is How to interpret that graph
at runtime to be very
efficient in balancing prefetching
reuse all those things we don't have
examples, for example Jaon Garra uses it
using our programming model
for your
libraries He saw that once you have This
synchronization can overlap Communications and
calculation you can really optimize the
Hardware you can do the balancing better
and you have to pay attention to nothing other than
increasing the size of the matrix do it
by hand or do it with this
programming mod  It is the same, we apply this
to the mpi programs. Our model,
you have an mpi program that runs on
a 100,000-node supercomputer, you put
programs with the Start SS, which is not
difficult, and then it allows you
again that at runtime you
can overlap Communications and  calculation
and I don't have time here to tell you that
the use of the interconnection network is done
very poorly in current computers and
because of the way in which they are programmed but
that if they are programmed with the starss we
can go faster and for
example we can  obtain l Impact or other
much faster programs The idea is
overlap let's communicate with calculation we
do
better scheduling This is the structure we started
developing programming model ago
in fact it is a continuation of something
we started 15 years ago for the c
node symmetric processors  gpus
Specific hardware class loos for
grid and for Cloud Okay it is eh you have the
same code on any machine a
single source of code to maintain it
that is important asynchronous Data Flow the
runtime This model Which models are
the good ones there are
very good programming models The problem  It's that people
make a programming model that no
one uses, well, that's fine. It's a
very good exercise. If you want your
programming model to move forward,
you have to motivate people or force them to
use it. We're
lucky.  In large projects in
Europe such as Teraflu for multicore or
in Tex where we are leaders, the BSC
coordinators are large projects with
supercomputing centers. This is
the center that Fabich named a
moment ago today. This one, too,
was also named by the
IPCC. Well  well we have large
applications that are being programmed
some of them are already with our
programming model not
so large applications for multicore and the code
is the same the code is the same
We also have at the Spanish level it is a
project that we lead it is a
5 project  million euros where what
we did was And I think that would have to be
done everywhere to be in
contact with the applications people and
create
interdisciplinary groups to optimize those
applications and to prepare them for the
future Hardware is imp I can tell you
not to say  that programs that once they have been
touched with the tools, the
inside has been analyzed a little, the
same program has increased
the speed by three or four. That is a lot of
money in a supercomputer because it
means that in a quarter of the
time we are  obtaining the same
results and that is valid for
any type of platform,
eh tools, I'm not going to tell you, there's
a little talk about vampir And so on But the
idea is again from an mpi program
without knowing what that program does, in the end
we have the photograph of you  the
x-ray you have a bad lung you
have a bad liver and such Because that
part does not use the Hardware well you have to
change this you have to change another And
again we have from the top
to the multicor simulators below
a whole total chain to simulate the
behavior  of the
current architectures and the future ones I am going to go a
little quickly because we have already run out of
architectures, there are going to be many types of
architectures, right? There will be
homogeneous ones. I have given the example of China
as one more example of what if in the
supercomputer, first
the one that  Number one, only the
Hardware that they put in was the
interconnection network. They believe that in the
next thing they are doing, even the
processor will be theirs.
Importantly, this number is tremendous.
384 GB 15 W means 25 gigaflop per
watt, the machine is more  green today is 20
times worse then it is very very important there
will be architectures like this that is
being developed in Barcelona by r
was a doctoral student of mine who
also worked with Luis Villa is another
doctoral student I have that I have mentioned
before the L rabi the first was a
failure the second  I know that it is going to be
good and it is going to be a candidate to be
used in
supercomputers. This one has no
problem. The GPUs are going to continue with
their difficulties. The GPUs are not
vector machines. They execute very well
those very simple codes, those
loops that are  It totally paralyzes the
others suffer a lot and eh Well what I
said before we have to take into account
these issues
and power Power This is an
important issue it has come up before for a
long time the cost of electricity
during the life of the machine It
is higher  that the cost of the machine
is a tremendous problem that
has already made the architects, as you know, not able to,
throw in the towel. I
felt very uncomfortable because I said I
cannot continue my work of 25 years
because we cannot increase the speed
of the machines.  processors because they burn out
and we earn little Well, that is a very
serious issue for machines, so what
has been done for a long time Well, it
is always good to compare people, not
machines, machines do not complain
So the top Green was made
in agreement  and the idea is that they hold on
because here you can catch, you can catch or not,
the
500 the 500 fastest machines when
they execute the Impact you see how much energy they
have spent is divided and those that with
less energy do more operations
are on top, you see here I don't see  very good
but in the Green the number one of the
Green is number 115 in the top 500 it is
a prototype of the Blue jein that
remember that it will be the sequel okay
So here you have information here I
prepare a little the number one the
number two and  number three number
one for example 1.6 gflops per watt
is 115 number do is 353 it is
a machine with fpc it is not valid But well And
number three eh Number two after
this is the the fourth is a machine
with gpu the one from Tokyo agree what is
important is that most of the
500 machines are not green at all,
they spend a lot of energy for what they
produce And if we worry that
perhaps the user what he has obtained
has been  not valid because you don't see what
way to heat the environment without
obtaining good results But that's
not life and there are three machines that are
here I don't see it well from here But
well then look at these data this
is a stupid thing that I have done  but well,
simply that if we extrapolate
more than half a nuclear power plant, it
would be a bit unfair for that machine.
This is a processor, people
are already saying at risk. What things are
they going to do? This is a processor of envy, a chip that they predict they will
be there for.  For 2017, notice that
the chip is 20 teraflops, eh. And with this they
can make a machine in 2018
with 400 racks, an exaflop and 15 mw. eh. 15
mw would be a reasonable thing. 15 mw would be a
reasonable thing. The important thing is to notice.
These are chips.  for example this is the
power 5 here you have characteristics 4 cm
cu of silicon This is the inter u the Core
2 This is the one that the winner
let's say at the level of number of
processors okay And here they have
different characteristics of one of
the  Things that we are very happy about in
Barcelona is that
we have proposed to the community to make a
supercomputer with AR Ok and we have
received 8.5 million euros. We will make
a clear prototype of which almost
half is to make the prototype. We are
in close collaboration with AA.  and we
were aware. For two years now,
under the agreement that they were going to make
with Nvidia, that combination
could be one of the valid ones to make
not only supercomputers but also
telephones and
any other matter of being. You have here
information that I will leave you but  Let's go The
important thing is that we are very
excited because it is going to be a
very Green machine but a little more difficult to
develop in the sense that there are many more
cores than those that said, how many cores there are
per chip depends on the complexity of
each Core, no, but I believe  which is an
idea to follow for many of the
applications in the future there will be
specific supercomputers for
applications and I believe that the issue of
power of what is spent will be a
Driver to force us to make that a
reality
for that I am ending  It needs
a lot of education.
President Santos spoke yesterday to all those who
spoke. We have to change the way
we teach in universities. We
have to make
multidisciplinary teams and that is discipline
. You know, this is very difficult
because each one is the owner of his or her
subject.  He doesn't want to share but if
we don't share we won't move forward and for
example we do many
activities in the BSC This is one that we are
going to do This is the one from 2011 we are going to repeat
with it comes
W David Kirk eh I haven't brought it
unfortunately because I changed the
Powerpoint format  We organize with
Fabricio and Microsoft every two years the
BMW, which is not a car brand but
is the Barcelona multicore workshop
where very important people come from
all the companies Intel IBM
Microsoft and we are really there for two days
and as I say we have to
change  This, but I believe from the
school the thing that to me of the
recognition most everyone has been very
unfair but the one that I am most happy about
is that I was born in a town of 1200
inhabitants and they gave it to the only
school there where masters have given it
in my name so crazy 6 years ago
so I wanted to give you a
separate recognition there are not many more
kids well there are 120 there a little bit
of that from a little one they have to
start we have to start with these
technologies a little bit make the child of
tost tenes in parallel  These things
must be done in Education to make
this hardware increasingly more complex
than these applications that
Professor Hofc said we have to solve
can be solved efficiently,
education must be changed. This is the
place where the best football is played in the
world.
eh, why are you
laughing? It's true that some of us,
not Latinos, know that marstro is the
Mediterranean,
eh, our mother and such. I always say
that we gave it this name Because well,
marenostrum
is a sea that was always used so
that on the weekends we could go to  Seeing the
brides or grooms is not true because there has
been every battle and fear and
we made the computer crazy to say
that Barcelona was a meeting point
for doing
science. There was a lot of criticism about putting it
in the church, it was put for two reasons and
how  the joke, the first one because it didn't
fit anywhere in our
university says what is the second one for? say if it did
n't fit anymore well the second one is
because the rector of Then he was a
communist and he said what better use of a
church than to put in a computer the
truth is  The thing is that it is protected, the software
works quite well
and when Gabriel taught me, do you remember
Gabriel? You taught me the day before yesterday here
in the church, I say, Well, this more or
less fits here.
Now my mother is very religious, I am
respectful of religion, but when
they ask  That didn't fit anywhere else,
the church asked for permission
because it was a place where in the last 6
years when I was the dean of the
faculty in 1984 it was
desacralized, but then it had been a
garbage dump for 6 years. So
the marj was very happy.  very nice, have you
seen that to have exflow machines you
need at least 10 times the space
that is a 120 m church that doesn't fit
but we are in negotiations I am
only here today because tomorrow I have been
in my beloved Colombia for a week eh eh
I like it a lot  the r Bear that you say and
then well I have to go back
because if not they are going to kill me in Barcelona
Thank you very much and I would like you to
collaborate I
would like me to collaborate a lot in the
projects that Fabricio has mentioned but
I am also sure that with the
university  Manizales, as a representative
of Colombia, we are going to channel a large part
of the collaboration that we are going to do with
any computing center in
Colombia.
Thank you very much.